milestone logo this is the story of how
I died
narration once upon a time a single drop
of sunlight fell from the heavens and
from this small drop of Sun grew a magic
golden flower small drop of Sun traveled
93 million miles to fuck the rules of
photosynthesis also sunlight comes to
earth in beans not drops everyone knows
that it had the ability to heal the sick
and injured and was immediately
discovered by an evil witch I told you
she'd be important that was literally
thirty five seconds ago Mother Gothel
hoarded it's healing power and used it
to keep herself young for hundreds of
years
how does healing power translate into
reversing the aging process all she had
to do was sing a special song don't you
figure out how to do that in the first
place also the single drop of sunlight
fell to earth and sprouted a flower and
genetically precoded to only be magical
after this combination of words and
notes were song you mean you were
actually looking for a magical healing
flower that was created by a single drop
of Sun and you knew it existed
somehow King is a dick and doesn't
invent a magical Disney tune to make
this flower work so that more people
could use it in the future I'll give you
a hint
that's Rapunzel that's not a hint dude
that's just the answer
[Music]
how does Mother Gothel know that if she
sings the song to rapunzel that her hair
will still have the power to make her
young that's a huge risk to break into a
castle and hope that the magical flower
latched itself into Rapunzel's DNA also
geez is anyone actually guarding this
castle why just cutting the hair destroy
its power isn't it part of her DNA is it
it blonde at the roots holy Sh the king
and queen were in here too how did they
not hear that singing just like that God
jumping off an incredibly high balcony
without injury is accomplished with the
flick of a cape come to think of it how
and the witch get into that window in
the first place the kingdom's searched
and searched for they could not find the
princess kingdom is great at finding
hidden flowers but not so much at hidden
towers damnit Grinch whoever built this
tower installed the most impractically
placed lever for a Sun roof ever created
but wait your hair is tied way up in the
rafters somewhere doesn't it get tangle
oh
[Music]
the witch didn't even tell this girl a
fake birthday she is terrible at kidnap
based fake mothering security issues
continue to plague the castle 18 years
after Rapunzel's kidnapping clearly
these thieves knew that you could pry
open some place on the top of the castle
find an easily removable panel and
mission impossible the way down why not
just lock the tiara our way somewhere
and reduce the manpower required to
guard it also if you're going to
overkill security with 9 guards why not
have at least two of them watching the
tiara itself these guys somehow managed
to get off the rooftops of the castle
run through the main part of the kingdom
and exit the town without any resistance
and where is everybody I'm turning 18
what no self-respecting 18 year old
would waited this long to ask to go
outside the home or even to sneak out on
their own rapunzel fails at being a
teenager I want to see the floating
lights Mother Gothel was about to eat an
apple but she knew it would make her
look like even more of an asshole
if they appear every year on my birthday
mother see which mom the movies entire
central conflict is due to you not just
making up some fake birthday for your
fake daughter you hoped would never
realize she was the king's daughter
stupid witch this is also a decent time
to ask what the witches plan was for
whenever her daughter got old enough to
not take orders like was she thinking
she could keep 40 year-old Rapunzel here
with scary stories about the outside
world in this time
well she stays you go out every day for
great lengths of time how does this one
switch close all the windows and doors
in the entire home and turns this sunny
afternoon day out sided to pitch
darkness immediately um dresser cape
should totally be catching on fire right
now
how and where and why is there a sudden
spotlight that the guy who obviously
does not have the satchel suddenly has
the satchel
these horses have no choice but to do
what the humans tell them to so any
orders related by horses are virtually
known void in a world where animals know
things and understand situations this is
a stupid move thing flying off a cliff
just happens to snag on a tiny tree
branch cliche horse tackling by the way
what's riders planned once he grabs the
bag does he think he'll be able to get
back to the edge of the cliff without a
murderer's horse in his way
luckily the branch breaks so he never
has to answer that question they
survived this dead horse magically
reanimates to life before our very eyes
how did this asshole not die and find
the time to find a rock to hide behind
they both fell at the same time right
also since this horse can apparently
track like a bluetick hound why did it
not lead him straight to the rock either
that or you're telling me Ryder found
the time to also leave a false trail
after that fall despite the fact that
it's fairly well hidden I still can't
believe no one from the kingdom ever
found this place in 18 years like
they'll fire off lanterns on her
birthday hoping she sees them but can't
scour enough land in that time to find a
huge tower next to the waterfall you can
climb stone towers by stabbing
arrowheads into them Oh No
also pretty damn convenient he shows up
while Rapunzel's overprotective witch
mother is gone right thankfully he stays
knocked out for all this despite having
awakened from the first frying pan
knockout after about 20 seconds hazelnut
soup despite never once being a
characteristic of their relationship
Mother Gothel constantly interrupts
Rapunzel so that she can turn really
evil and give Rapunzel second thoughts
about how good her mother is mom falls
for the phony birthday request that
takes three days travel to get - uh yeah
no his face is completely broken and
when I promise something I never ever
break that promise man I hope she
promises to do me I mean in cartoon do
me wait I mean I want to squeeze him why
is he climbing down why didn't she just
lower him down with her hair
hey where'd the rest of her hair go also
who untied her hair from the hook at the
top of the tower
this horse is half bloodhound the real
issue is do I sent it for being cheap
comedy or for actually being related to
the plot also it's been three days and
this horse has been on a never-ending
sniff hunt for Ryder the whole time so
Rapunzel's hair wouldn't have been long
enough for use as a means in and out of
this tower until she was at least hit or
more so when Rapunzel was eight and
definitely old enough to know about the
secret passageway how the fuck is the
witch coming and going from the tower
wanted poster of person pictured does
not necessarily mean that this is the
person you're looking for Rapunzel's
hair should be filled with grass flowers
dirt and bugs by now somehow this
distracts everyone from taking Ryder and
getting a reward it's funny but not
realistic and I demand realism from
Disney fairy tale cartoons damn it this
guy was done finding the moment she said
dream but pulled out an axe and stalked
over to her simply to surprise the
audience well no since Mozart was an
18th century composer and what era is
this link definitely way before Mozart
right this guy's hook literally destroys
several piano keys but then he just
keeps on playing as though none of the
notes he needed to play fell on now
destroyed keys this is definitely the
first place I'd go after finding out my
fake daughter was kidnapped I can
understand some of these manly warrior
beast dudes actually having a quaint
non-violent domesticated ambition but
all of them this entire pub scene would
have played out a whole lot differently
in Westeros this ass wall actually
destroys a window with this Rapunzel's
hair should have been trampled during
this musical number hell it should have
burned in that fire back there I fought
the guards which mom totally does
nothing for the entire last two minutes
of song so the guards can come in and
cause an action sequence that keeps her
and her daughter separated by plot Oh
lay off Maximus you suck and you
definitely suck at tracking if he were
on their trail you would have found them
by now you found three days oh damn you
even figured out the secret lever to
when did you get good at this remember
all she cares about is staying young to
do that she needs to get her daughter
back so what is she doing just
spectating the last five minutes I can
buy a horse who can sword fight
certainly but I know at some point near
the end you're gonna make the climax
feel a long life or death in consequence
II and I'll be the guy raising my hand
at the back clearing my throat saying
Hank sword fighting horse
said the guy who just improvised a solo
verse of a spontaneous thug show tune on
the bar in a pub that's a new stomach
spleen intestines and probably some
other vital as well huge hospital bill
is huge
Maximus decides that whatever this dam
was built for potentially flooding the
valley down below is worth catching this
one guy feet surfing way to go Maximus
you are one terrible fucking horse dude
this flood washes everyone away but
doesn't actually injure or kill anyone
this rock must have been pretty damn
unstable to begin with for this amount
of water at the base to completely
topple the thing right magic hair has a
delayed response in this single instance
of the song being sung because drama oh
good they found a possible exit but
these rocks are weak too heavy to move
before one drowns so technically they're
still screwed right I mean right by once
it's cut it turns brown and loses its
power and stops growing for some reason
how come Rapunzel doesn't notice her
mother zombie is aging between magic
hair songs Maximus is so obsessed he
didn't even bother getting
reinforcements to help him catch this
guy so during an intricate musical
number inside a tight bar the hairs no
problem but now in the open space of the
kingdom suddenly it's a problem all that
can hair from earlier somehow contained
in this everyone audience and main
character included totally knows what's
up but Looby still has 40 more minutes
of some kind of bullshit 40 random girl
no one has ever seen before it looks
exactly like the child who was kidnapped
18 years ago does not arouse any
suspicions but the fuck is going on
they're dancing now they're hiding from
guards and eating cupcakes dancing the
same day and snap their pick up a
library still dancing are they in
several places at once the director said
let's have Maximus eat 14 apples it'll
make him look like 14 assholes it's hard
to believe that a king and queen this
kind and carrying have an absolute
disaster of human beings working for
them each of these boats is releasing
more lanterns than the boat has room for
people even if every person released two
lanterns he definitely didn't have to
fragile lanterns when they boarded that
boat mother dothis plan entirely rides
on the hope that rider sees the twins
from a boat she couldn't possibly have
known he would be on
Rapunzel asked this instead of turning
around to see whatever troubling thing
he's so obviously looking at until said
troubling thing has gone out of sight
Rapunzel just believes the evil twin
story after one glance at a distant boat
on a foggy honest evening this is the
first time these fucking guards have
noticed anything
this horse hated Flynn and was part of
the team chasing him to begin with but
after a few short hours of spending time
with Flynn and Rapunzel the horse has
concern for Rapunzel safety also the
horse has concern oh damn this Disney
fairy tale cartoon really got dark going
it's pretty hard to believe the king and
queen are not only caring and good but
also believe in hanging people for the--
brie hazelnut soup look if the mural you
saw with a child that could only be you
didn't jog your memory then these
patterns you've been subliminally
drawing all these years definitely
wouldn't have is the movie suggesting
Rapunzel remembers that mobile and her
parents above her crib that I mentioned
that these guards are the worst possible
people in for jobs also despite the fact
that we saw plenty of other guards at
the beginning of this scene they decide
that the unruly prisoner is best left of
the guys who just got beat up and offer
no help whatsoever
Rapunzel believes that the truly evil
not mother who has been holding her in
this tower for 18 years and concocted a
devious plan to get her back after
escaping will just let her walk out with
no problem
The Dude's back at the snuggly duckling
did not give two shits about Ryder but
somehow a horse was able to convince
them to stage a daring escape for him
because love and the horse passed
English in college this movie is
basically challenging me to hate it
right now also mine breaks the fourth
wall with director camera reaction shop
okay even if these idiots could somehow
have calculated the exact trajectory and
distance of this jump thing how the fuck
did they communicate with the horse to
let him know how to do his part and
where to be also his balls are crushed
now but whatever you brought them here
I'm sure it took a serious amount of
horse charades with another musical
number to tell these dumb criminals
exactly what he needed
why didn't you just do that in the first
place
why was she tied up in a room if he
didn't already plan on doing that anyway
if you let me save him I will go with
you
contradictory statements in case you get
any ideas about following us who's going
to take off his shackles then Flynn cuts
a girl's hair without her for knowledge
or permission I know why he does it and
it works but still rob a girl of her
special power and cut her hair all in
one fell swoop dick move random hair
cutting mirror shard integral to the
entire plot just happens to be within
riders reach so he can do this also
couldn't have done this after getting
you why does the which rapidly age after
the hairs cut off she brushes it in
sings and it makes her young and she
slowly ages until she does that all over
again but this ending suggests just
being in proximity to the hair does a
great deal to keep one looking young
largely cancelling out the power of the
brushing and song bit this chameleons
straight up murders a bitch if this had
been Maximus or Ryder this fall would
have hurt one bit after a movie were the
only magic is hair a magic tear will now
scoop in and steal the movie because
Disney I guess it's true love's tear
right this guy told us he was dead and
guess what just joking
he opened us with tricky language so
there could be a surprise and if
Rapunzel's tears can heal him then
surely her hair can still grow blond
instead of this hideous hideous
non-healing and worthless brown hair
neither the King nor the Queen say one
damn word this whole movie all as well
and we got to skip all the
diaper-changing and all those awkward
years I saw that guy went on to become
the most famous concert pianist in the
world and he can believe it I don't and
this guy well he eventually found from
love just not with this chick
thanks to Maximus crime in the kingdom
disappeared almost overnight wrong asked
it most of the apples because he's an
asshole beloved by all she led her
kingdom with all the Grace and wisdom
that her parents did before her
hopefully she changed the guard hiring
policies though I finally said yes
eugen after staying silent the entire
movie Rapunzel shows up to help narrate
the end if she just sitting quietly
listening to Flynn tell the whole story
without once interjecting to correct him
as she does here I think not
despite movies best efforts I still kind
of hate this guy
[Music]
you
what's a man kissing again someday you
may not mind so much Rapunzel all she
had to do was sing a special song glad
you can you want like a Wars movie good
I think I got the best one be guest be
our guest put our service for the test
tae-young throw me the idol I throw you
the whip give me the whip yes senior I
didn't want to have to do this but you
leave me no choice
here comes the smolder my real name is
Eugene Fitzherbert
that's the worst name I ever heard whoa
I think I just figured something out
Davis you can imagine what happened next
if I am only 16 and this is California
not Kentucky considering the rocky
terrain that's really you must expect me
to attack whatever powder naturally I
find it simple cancers are kept up there
[Music]